après les frappes qui ont visé le centre
de denis proulx la question ici est de
savoir si elle serait un prélude à
d'autres frappes à venir ni pro est une
ville d'une grande importance
stratégique puisqu'elle permet le
ravitaillement de l'armée ukrainienne
sur tous les fronts le front sud est et
nord le but de la russie serait entre
autres d' entraver l'acheminement des
armes jusqu'à cette ville des
infrastructures de transport serait dans
ce cas une cible majeure c'est l'avis du
marc denis pro que nous avions rencontré
il ya quelques jours
il va sans dire que nous avons peur
qu'ils bombardent les infrastructures
ils le font déjà en fait nous ne savons
pas quelles sont leurs plans je pense et
des experts militaires israéliens me
l'ont dit que logistiquement ils ne
peuvent pas arrêter le transfert des
armes même si le bombarde les trouver
les israéliens ont dit que ce qui les a
surpris fait que pour que la guerre soit
un succès les russes auraient dû nous
bombarder pendant cinq jours d'affilée
sans s'arrêter mais ils ne l'ont pas
fait il pensait que nous les
accueillerons avec des fleurs et que
nous aurions peur que le gouvernement
s'en furet et que céline ce qui
s'envolerait pour londres cette illusion
explique tout
le maire denis proulx insiste aussi sur
l'importance symbolique de sa ville
censée être troisième capitale de
l'empiré russe sous catherine ii
aujourd'hui se rajoute à cette
importance symbolique une importance
humanitaires et stratégiques